Well,
how are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish. I tell you that firefighters from the
city of Las Vegas came to put out a
fire in a business located near
Jones Boulevard and Big Strike. See the
images. This fire started
after  five in the morning firefighters
said that the fire consumed the entire
roof fortunately there were no injuries
however the cause of this incident is still being investigated
and new details have come to light
about the priest accused of sexual abuse of
minors a
police arrest report  Metropolitan indicates that
Reinaldo Crespín began abusing a
minor since 2014
Detectives say that this happened in a
house in his church and in a vehicle
Clark County School District police say that he resigned from his job
as a teacher in  Heck Elementary and
last February 7 however none
of the incidents are related to
students from this school  and from this it
emerges to be that it is located behind the
boon will soon reach its
final stage workers began
building this massive structure with
andy devices inside
for several months it is said that this will be
the largest high resolution screen
in the world is expected  that the
project is finished by 2023 and
the cold temperatures continue but
soon everything will change we will have a
sunny day with highs in the 50s still
shenzhen will feel colder than
normal this cold air will last
until Friday warmer temperatures are expected
by the end  of the week I am
Cristian Cásseres with his brief
informative of ínsula a Spanish good
day
[Music]